that's impeachment obsession leading to
an all-out battle on Capitol Hill Pelosi
and her pals plowing ahead by finally
holding a vote on laying down new ground
rules about impeachment the move leading
to some very heated exchanges take a
look it's about the truth it's about the
Constitution
this is soviet-style rules don't run a
sham process they don't want to see a
proper investigation they are trying to
impeach the President of the United
States less than 13 months before an
election no one is above the law and
shifty shifty where he could become a
witness that's right
Republicans say they make all the Intel
chair to testify here's my challenge to
mr. Schiff you want to be Ken Starr be
Ken Starr come to the Judiciary
Committee be the first witness and take
every question asking you starting with
your own involvement with the
whistleblower I can see it now a shifty
shift pleads the fifth right one I do
want to ask you though there's fires in
Southern California and shifts district
and there's rolling blackouts all over
California and Nancy and the whole
delegation is in DC voting on trying to
impeach Trump for a phone call does that
look at a touch to you know it sounds
like you're desperate for an argument is
there members of Congress as speaker of
the house right and they are trying to
hold you know the president the
executive accountable for what they see
as outlandish possibly impeachable high
crimes and even though people's homes
are burning down and people have no
power I don't think she's the fire chief
but here's a delegation let me just let
me respond to this I think the GOP
forever and ever was saying process is
the issue well now the process jesse is
going to be open and public and on the
record people will testify they were
arguing process because they were losing
on the facts and now they don't have
process and even today more damning
testimony John Bolton's top aide quit
the White House yesterday so he could
testify today so to me this is like oh
the whistleblower
Oh who's the whistleblower whistleblower
is wrong it's secondhand then it was
this is the perfect cause that's still
the facts this is a perfect cause as a
president and then no quid pro quo we do
this all the time and now all of this is
going down the drain and I think you're
starting to see people say you know this
could be a problem Jesse I'm not so sure
about that one and we do know who the
whistleblower is Greg I do we but we're
not allowed to say look I think that
I've never seen a media so careful to do
the bidding of a political party there's
a huge story in front of them the story
of who the whistleblower is did he work
with Biden did he work with Schiff did
he work with Brennan did he work with
DNC operatives to help initiate the the
collusion narrative the excuses of
course hey we're protecting him from
danger danger danger that's a lie
they're protecting him from scrutiny as
well can I interrupt sure maybe that's
not the issue Greg maybe it's that all
that he has said has been corroborated
by other people no you know what it's
interesting what he has said was in the
transcript that we already knew we're
okay with what's in the transcript so
you're building a train of opinions of
concern without actually something of
Merit being there this is like David
Copperfield you know what he made a
giant building disappear this is that in
Reverse it's a it appears huge but it's
still an illusion and a trick on the
American people you have the Democrats
for what three years talking about oh my
god colluding to undo an election we
we're watching collusion between the
Democrats in the media we have no
protection against this kind of thing
they're gonna get they're gonna try to
unseat a president because they can't
beat him on a flimsy accusation and you
know coming off the heels of the Russia
hoaxed and it's hard to really believe
what you read from anonymous sources in
the mainstream media about what's going
on and it's really hard to follow I
think and also maybe one you saw
something light but I didn't see the the
drips and drabs that we got from today's
testimony from Tim Morrison who was the
national security expert on Russia that
apparently he said yes he was aware of
it he didn't have concerns about it and
he was cool so I don't think that burned
what Bill Taylor had said which is right
but he said that his concerns didn't
rise to the level of right well
obviously he's right you have to go with
what that person says and that is
why I think the Republicans pounding the
table for a month about process and
finally getting to this point because
the Democrats were we're not gonna be
forced to this point unless the
Republicans made it big issue out of it
and remember Nancy Pelosi the speaker
was very reluctant to even bring up
impeachment and now she waited like six
weeks to have this vote now they have
this vote and now they have six
committees this is what the thing that I
can't understand like how do you
coordinate six different committees that
the infighting the staff it's just it's
I think in the long run it's a net
negative yes you did say about three or
four months previous that she wasn't
going to do impeachment if it was going
to be along partisan lines and now we
saw the vote Emily and it is along
partisan lines yeah exactly the
exception of two Democrats that are
afraid for their chairs I had a poster
of David Copperfield in my room growing
up I can I speak to those battleground
state poles for a second and I don't
want to like wax philosophical but to me
the underwear yeah are actually because
I it spoke to me that the Democrats have
totally lost the American voter on
impeachment and the underbelly of em
right the majority of Americans support
or a plurality an investigation right
why because we support process and
fairness and evidence and everyone keeps
saying well this is a political process
it's not legal but why do we have the
legal framework that we do because
Americans fundamentally believe that
that structure should be fair that's why
we throw out entire murder convictions
if evidence is not obtained in a fair
manner and shift to me he's he's in the
minority of the minority in his
conclusion he doesn't realize how
off-putting it is how repelling it is to
the average American that is once to
have faith in the process final point
for the Democrats crying and shouting
about a bombshell this whole time then
why aren't any Americans persuaded yet
why have they all responded to these
polls and said we believe in the
investigation not yet we saw the
bombshell - it's not there yet did you
want to say something before we go to
commercial break Greg I want to say a
lot of things but but what but I'll just
end here and say that they they're
admitting this as a political process
it's purely a political
process yes yes it's all yes but don't
let Politico get my ear you're missing
my point okay that rather if they're
trying to they're trying to solve a
political problem that is Trump they
can't beat him in the election so
they're using politics to beat him and
you're right
America's seeing through this I think
this is gonna be a whale that swallows
the Democrats all and think about this
America is dealing with a lot of stuff
right you're gonna have it you're having
an election next year you're gonna have
primaries and debates plus you got Trump
who's forcing to himself
you're the one to throw another ball to
juggle this impeachment so Democrats are
gonna fall apart it's gonna swap them
they're gonna be a mess and I'm gonna
love ya and Democrats are just gonna say
you know what oh look at these
impeachment polls they keep going up and
out more and more Americans say we have
to move this guy the only thing lowering
the law the polls that are worse than
that or polls in the media and the polls
on the saying there's a reality